what you're seeing here at the picture
in pictures what the folks in Sarajevo
see cure your job as a producer how do
you facilitate between them the job of
the produce I think's rather production
process is to constantly problem-solve
to foresee problems even before they
happen don't think that your films
become better because of the amount of
money that you plow into it don't care
where the ideas come from you can have a
great idea come from your location's
department you can have a great idea
come from you know a PA do good things
about cutting on on digital just you
have much more because it's faster you
can try different things again you have
more time to try experiment I think the
most successful directors that I've seen
at work are the ones who are leaders and
really work well with the different
departments it's not about money it's
about what the process is and what the
story is the fact that this was
organized and that we can communicate
with young filmmakers in Eastern Europe
that's where the technology has really
served us very well and I think that's
one of the big positive aspects of what
we can do today thank you